c'est l'heure des comptes dans le
sud-est de la france après les
inondations des entreprises durement
pénalisé des lotissements détruits et
beaucoup d'interrogations
le système dallaire at il fonctionné
pourquoi construire en zone inondable
trois questions à nicolas sarkozy
ministre de l'intérieur bonsoir et
incite à l'avant soir des larmes arrêt
des fleurs pour la commémoration du
11-septembre cérémonie poignante à new
york les noms des 2800 une victime ont
été lus l'un après l'autre
nous gagnerons la guerre contre le
terrorisme a répété de george bush et à
propos de terrorisme un témoignage en
exclusivité celui d'un français arrêté
en géorgie à la frontière tchétchène à
khaled ould ali clame son innocence mais
il risque 15 ans de prison
le débat sur la prostitution avec une
première judiciaire à bordeaux ce sont
des clients qui sont poursuivis
officiellement pour exhibition sexuelle
leur éventuelle condamnation pourrait
ouvrir la voie à une interdiction de
fait de la prostitution comme en suède
enfin la sncf supprime les wagons
fumeurs en première classe dans tous les
tgv les tests réalisés sur la ligne
atlantique ont été conclus rend bientôt
une expérience similaire ce sont ramenés
en seconde classe
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
si vous habitez le sud est vous l'avez
constaté le ciel est plus clément le
soleil est toujours là partout l'heure
est au nettoyage et à l'évaluation des
dégâts ou plutôt presque partout aramon
dans le gard le village le plus touché
les bottes reste indispensable et les
secours continuent les recherches
un homme était porté disparu ce matin
encore l'histoire vous allez le voir
s'est bien terminée sur place virginie
fiche accréditives et lorsqu'ils sont
entrés dans la cour de la maison
les militaires de la sécurité civile
redoutait le pire et puis sur le pas de
sa porte
joseph imperturbable plusieurs mails à
plusieurs changements à 77 ans joseph
n'a pas voulu céder devant le désastre
hier sa femme a été évacuée lui est
resté derrière sans regrets mais dans
l'agitation les nouvelles se sont perdus
le doute s'est installé
c'est la famille qui le chai qui
cherchait ce monsieur donc
ils ont pris contact puisque vous avez
vu votre famille donc le compte-rendu
n'a pas été fait on se retrouve là la
toile on ne peut pas le parent proche et
savoir ce que dans l'affolement
reviennent pas rendre compte aujourd'hui
encore militaires des secouristes se
sont employés à lever les incertitudes
sur le sort de trois personnes dont on
restait sans nouvelle malheureusement
les 10 moments ne sont pas toujours
aussi joyeux que dans le cas de joseph
ce matin lors d'une nouvelle
reconnaissance
une cinquième victime a été découverte
on a retrouvé une victime après être
passé deux fois dans sa maison alors
trouver quand l'eau était descendu les
premières fois on en est les dans
certaines habitations il y avait 2
mètres 50 ou plus d'eau il y avait les
meubles quichotte et gravats des
plafonds effondrés et c'est à présent
seule la décrue total libérera les
esprits du poids du doute ce soir un
mètre d'eau laissait encore planer
l'angoissent dans plusieurs villages du
département l'eau ne s'est pas encore
retiré comme le montre à ces images
tournées ce matin c'est aussi le cas de
plusieurs villages dans d'autres
départements
et puis ailleurs löw n'a pas seulement
envahi les maisons
elle a aussi balayé les maisons à
collias reportage yannick un aussi beau
jour dans ja mais les deux appartements
et là il y avait aujourd'hui il y avait
le jean délavé les plaques d'égout
et aujourd'hui il ne reste plus rien à
part les dalles de béton laroche est mis
à nu le gardon et montée d'une vingtaine
de mètres dans la journée de lundi à la
hauteur du pont brive envoie là-bas les
maisons ont été renversés balayé on se
croirait presque après un tremblement de
terre ou le passage de l'ouragan reste
droit par le garage c'est tout sûrement
rien plus rien et d'habiller tel
vêtement partir qu'on ne suis pas rien
c'était ici le sous sol de la maison
aujourd'hui laitages a disparu emporté
plus loin avant d'évacuer ce jeune
couple a pu sauver l'essentiel des
chiens ses principales le reste c'est
derrière vous une grosse solidarité dans
le village de collias qui nous permet
aussi de remonter un peu la pente parce
que c'est vrai que on a du monde a les
héros cueillie avant même que que la
crue la rime depuis qu'ils avaient déjà
il conseillait trade en aide à la maison
par le plafond tous les réfugiés ont pu
être relogés chez les villageois à
collias la solidarité n'est pas un vain
mot
les vêtements affluent les amis viennent
donner un coup de main pour vider les
maisons dévastées
il n'y a pas eu des victimes à collias
mais les dégâts matériels sont telles
qu'il faudra beaucoup de temps pour
oublier l'activité économique risque
également de s'en ressentir sérieusement
on apprend par exemple que 40 % du
vignoble gardot a été touchée vignes
abîmés ou détruites
les vendanges venait à peine de débuter
par ailleurs l'activité nombreux
commerçants et artisans est quasiment
paralysée nathalie jourdan virgili ado
il n'y a plus rien pour la pétrir la
farine restera là sur le trottoir dans
la réserve
une chaîne de bras des centaines de sacs
et de cartons d'emballages à jeter je te
les employés les envoyer ma maison your
soul
et sous l'eau un peu plus haut dans la
rue
l'institut de beauté de virginie ouvert
il ya deux ans un investissement de 40
mille euro emportée par les eaux on va
pas est décédé à quatre mois cd qui
avait investi tout son argent dedans et
ces deux sentiments d'abord je voulais
continuer pour faire marcher marcher
marcher toute façon j'ai plein gaulin du
tout entrepreneurs commerçants artisans
ils sont aussi des habitants d'aramon
doublement touché la chambre des métiers
va les épauler dans leur démarche auprès
des assurances ne signez rien en urgence
que les dossiers vont être longs mais il
faut qu'il soit pointu ne rien oublier
dans cette agence immobilière
l'inventaire est vite fait tout ce qui
est administratif tout ce qui est buron
et lure la vibration
tout est détruit à 100% à recommencer
comme pour une nouvelle ouverture
il faut avancer notre association à nous
n'est pas trop grave a rapporté pertes
humaines et qu'a eu sur le village et en
faire le maximum pour faire très vite
puisque notre métier c'est la vente et
location de maison et je crois qu'ils
rappellent les gens là malheureusement à
reloger reprendre le travail et penser à
l'avenir
ils vont tout faire pour tenter
d'oublier la catastrophe ou plus vite
bonsoir thierry escudier vous êtes chef
d'entreprise une entreprise spécialisée
dans l'emballage vous avez 50 employés
vos ateliers sont sous l'eau que vous
manque-t-il maintenant pour reprendre
votre activité d'abord l'aide des
pompiers nous manque beaucoup de
beaucoup de travail pour tout
débarrasser d'un usine
l'aide des pompiers ou autre nous
d'autres personnes les militaires des
bateaux pour pouvoir y accéder parce que
on a absolument aucun bateau on nous
passe à côté un bateau alors que l'homme
a de l'eau jusqu'aux épaules et on ne
répond pas donc il faut d'énormes moyens
après que lisa sion 1 soit passé pour
pouvoir remettre l'activité économique
est en route
juste une perte assurée on pense que
l'on est toujours bien sûr et on voit sa
gamme de justin les comptes officiels
étaient bien ou non et vous pensez
pouvoir reprendre une activité normale
comme elle l'était avant pour pour le
reprendre une activité normale en
extérieur on espère toujours dans
combien de temps
c'est encore difficile à l'estimé
puisque cet après midi j'ai pu me rendre
à pied mais avec de l'eau jusqu'aux
épaules c'est à dire plus d'un mètre
cinquante d'eau jusque dans l'entreprise
et c'est encore difficile d'évaluer les
dégâts parce qu'il y avait un gros trou
d'eau j'ai l'impression que vous vous
sentez un peu seul je me sens
extrêmement seul dans l'immédiat la
solidarité les justes de mes employés
qui chaque fois que j'ai rencontrés
m'ont soutenue de mes fournisseurs et de
mes clients est principalement des
salariés qui sont à 80 % des familles
darmon et qu'il faut bon dany médias
qu'ils assurent leur maison qui
nettoient leurs maisons mais je pense
aussi qu'il faut pérenniser leur emploi
pour l'avenir merci thierry escudier et
bon courage
alors les réparations justement dans de
nombreuses communes il est encore trop
tôt
marsillargues par exemple dans l'hérault
reste est couverte ce matin d'une
épaisse couche de boue on estime que 60
mille foyers sont toujours privés de
téléphone dans le gard et le vaucluse
dès que les conditions le permettront
les ingénieurs de l'équipement
s'activeront c'est déjà le cas à
sommières benoît gadret thierry simonet
7h ce matin sur l'autoroute a9
cette équipe qui roule à grande vitesse
on l'appelle le samu du téléphone une
équipe unique en france qui n'intervient
qu'en cas de crise majeure
les interventions vont de 2 24 heures à
trois semaines un point donc le canton
par on a absolument aucune idée du temps
que ça va durer le chantier du jour
c'est ce central téléphonique à
sommières
il ya 48 heures il y avait ici de m dos
depuis 5000 abonnés sont privés de
téléphone
l'électronique lots non je me fait bon
ménage donc que ça c'est à charge c'est
à remplacer tous remplacés représente
six mois de travail
alors l'équipe va sortir sa botte
secrète un central téléphonique mobile
qu'elle a fait venir de son qg en
bretagne dans la rue les habitants
sinistrés se réjouissent onic
complètement points si on s'aperçoit que
pour lui le téléphone c'est absolument
vital
alors quand vous voyez ce camion
arrivait cajou aux camions arrivés tard
un peu d'espoir ce central mobile c'est
un peu comme un coeur artificiel un
organe provisoire que seuls ces
spécialistes savent branche étant les
connexions sont complexes des gens tout
ce qui va avoir le téléphone de nouveaux
quoi le plus vite possible et ils sont
très heureux aussitôt qu'on leur remet
les alignant en place vous qu'est ce que
ça représente pour vous justement
d'aider comme ça
présent au moins de rendre service rue
ville à quelque chose
les travaux devraient durer une bonne
partie de la nuit
demain les habitants de sommières
pourront enfin téléphoner l'équipe
d'urgence se rendra alors sur un autre
chantier
ça va mieux aussi dans les transports
tous les trains circuleront normalement
demain a indiqué la sncf mais des
retards de 15 à 20 minutes sont à
prévoir entre nîmes et montpellier
vous le savez en circule aussi à nouveau
sur les autoroutes
en revanche certaines voies secondaires
restent impraticables à lunel reportage
live de la mornais pierre bon jaws f on
dirait un barrage mais c'est un pont
submergé par une rivière dont la cote
est encore aujourd'hui à 4 mètres au
dessus de la normale pour la direction
départementale de l'équipement un pont
coupé c'est un axe de déviation à
trouver des dégâts a estimé
des mesures de sécurité à prendre je
vais refaire le point avec les rôles
assure justement de voir pour coordonner
nos moyens de 20
avec les romains l'avaient dérobé
première tâche des veillées la route des
carcasses d'arbre charriés par la crue
une manière de prendre de l'avancé sur
les travaux dès que l'eau aura baissé
que le pont redeviendra praticable
ensuite cela peut paraître une évidence
mais il faut mettre le camion en travers
de la route pour bien faire comprendre
au public que le pont est paré et
dangereux le fus impressionné par
l'absence de civisme c'est tout à fait
le terme des gens qui ne respectent pas
les routes barrées et les panneaux et
malgré tout les dispositifs physiques
que l'on met en place les gens roulent
sur nos panneaux des places nos
barrières et veulent franchir et valérie
s'est aventuré à franchir
il est tout à fait et faire et c'est
pour cette raison là j'ai demandé à mes
agents de mettre en place le camion qui
physiquement intégral cat cat ou autre
voie de goethe
voilà ce qui énerve la dde exemple en
plein centre ville sinistrée de
sommières
cet embouteillage n'a pas lieu d'être
les barrières bloquent pourtant l'accès
de cette rue mais faute d'un gendarme
pour les surveiller des automobilistes
passent outre
résultat les opérations de déblayage
sont considérablement ralenties
et quand on sait qu'il y en a pour des
mois de travaux mieux vaut ne pas
prendre de retard
merci nicolas sarkozy d'être avec nous
vous y étiez désir matin sur les lieux
de la catastrophe merci d'être avec nous
car on va parler des causes maintenant
de ce sinistre est sûre tout son
caractère meurtrier dans ces régions
habitué pourtant aux inondations premier
sujet d'interrogation l'alertent at elle
était donnée assez vite
apparemment les procédures au
fonctionner pour détecter les crues
peut-être alors faudra-t-il créer
d'autres instruments yasmina farber
patrice bruyères à chaque rencontre il
doit se justifier raconter sa nuit de
secours comment il a averti les
habitants
l'alerté a été donnée déjà c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas pu passer chez tout le
monde
donc à partir du moment où on n'est pas
passés chez tout le monde les combats
intimes qui est des gens qui se
plaignent dans la cour du collège
d'aramon la polémique alimente toutes
les conversations et sinistrés veulent
comprendre pourquoi ils n'ont pas été
évacués plus tôt
ces banques et c'est tout le monde au
club soda n'gola et moins aux heures je
dormais encore dans ma maison et si ma
femme ma femme et ma bêtise mais s'est
inquiété des feux des pompiers on était
quatre noms liés quoi on était quatre se
noyer
vers 22 heures les cloches ont sonné
pour prévenir du danger mais le sait
déjà là il était trop tard ça me gratte
un village au pied car toujours reçu de
l'eau il doit y avoir des sirènes pour
avertir les gens mais non c'est pas vrai
que le tocsin comme il a sonné que ont
brûlé en temps on n'a rien entendu
seal alert a été chaotique c'est aussi
parce que cette crue du gardon n'était
pas prévu à demi mots le maire soulan
visible le temps pose des services de
rita le système d' alerte au niveau des
crues du gardon pour notre secteur n'a
pas ramené ce qui l'aurait durham
certaines puisqu'on n'a jamais été
prévenus qu'une crue énorme qu'elle est
arrivée sur la commune difficile
d'apaiser les esprits après une telle
catastrophe difficile de trouver les
mots justes pour expliquer un drame qui
laisse les habitants d'aramon totalement
déboussolée alors nicolas sarkozy les
procédures ont elles fonctionner et sont
elles suffisamment efficace bon d'abord
les procédures ont fonctionné mais il
faut bien comprendre parce qu'on ne sait
pas ce que dit le maire oui mais on
comprend rien à ce qui s'est passé si on
n'a pas la mesure de la violence de ce
qui s'est déroulé un milliard de mètres
cubes d'eau sont tombés en 24 heures
tenez vous bien c'est l'équivalent 24
heures de la pluviométrie d'une année
avec le premier ministre nous étions à
sobeys et une vague de dix mètres de
haut qui a déferlé
nous avons vu des véhicules porter à la
hauteur du premier étage des immeubles
qui ont été inondées jusqu'au deuxième
étage dans cette région cévenole
ce sont des véritables cyclones qui se
sont abattus mais en a un peu l'habitude
d'une certaine manière un peu l'habitude
de se noie de président c'est important
cette violence là mais d hiver sommes là
l'habitude donc il faut que notre pays
retrouve la culture du risque notamment
dans cette région cévenole dont vous
avez raison de rappeler que les orages
sont d'une extrême violence allant nous
travaillons et punis
la ministre de l'environnement et
peut-être faut-il adapter un certain
nombre de dispositifs sera le lieu par
exemple est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
pour ces orages d'extrême violence
déclenchée un type d' alerte de type
cyclonique cette attaque de type rouge
où les autorités pourraient interdire
aux gens de sortir de chez eux
il faut comprendre aussi et je veux
rendre hommage aux sauveteurs et à tous
ceux qui ont fait un travail remarquable
et qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas à se
retrouver au centre d'une polémique
quand la nature se développe avec une
telle violence que c'est pas facile de
prévenir des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de gens qui se trouve chez eux
qu'ils n'écoutent pas touche la radio
les radios locales ont fait un travail
formidable
je pense y compris à france inter chacun
s'est donné tout le mal possible et
imaginable mais mettez-vous à la place
de sow maire d'une petite commune
comment voulez vous qu en pleine nuit il
a réveillé tout le monde
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que la
stratégie face aux catastrophes
naturelles doit sans doute être
renforcées et que chaque crise nous
devons tirer des leçons
la ministre de l'environnement prépare
un plan en la matière il faut qu'on
adapte nos moyens pour que la prochaine
fois on soit encore mieux organisés mais
à la différence de ce qui s'est passé
pour la tempête de 99
météo france a bien fait son travail
évaluant quand même un taux et
sous-ensembles alors vous savez il ya il
y à une malheureuse c'est exact mais je
vais vous dire une chose
nous étions avec le premier ministre et
une dame m'a dit vous savez on était à
quelques centaines de mètres du rhône
elle s'étonnait vernon 2d vous savez lui
s'est tenu tranquille c'est le petit
ruisseau qui est devenu fou comment vous
voulez qu météo france puisse prévenir
que des petits ruisseaux de rien du tout
devienne tout d'un coup le réceptacle
d'une vague de dix mètres de hauteur
il faut comprendre qu'on ne peut pas
tout prévoir
alors pas de risque zéro ça c'est le
risque zéro ne peut briguer une vraie
colère aujourd'hui mais la colère il est
normal
d'abord il faut penser aux victimes aux
gens qui ont tout perdu et ces gens
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent nous disent
deux choses d'abord comment va être
indemnisés pour pouvoir vivre et ça je
suis venu apporter des réponses précises
en termes de calendrier
et deuxième chose et c'est tout à fait
normal
ils disent qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour tirer les conséquences et notamment
en termes d'équipements structurants ce
soir deux points essentiels mesures noté
alors vous ne parlerez de ce calendrier
je pense que ça intéressera directement
le chef d'entreprise qui étaient avec
nous tout à l'heure d'abord ce second
sujet d'interrogation l'urbanisation la
région est dynamique elle accueille
chaque année de nouveaux arrivants mais
apparemment on continue de bâtir en zone
inondable karine comazzi pascal pons on
connaît ces peuples humour des gendarmes
mais à sommières c'est tout ce qui reste
à la brigade les locaux sont
inutilisables et deux appartements de
fonction sont dévastés le lundi matin on
a continué à faire notre commission
puis on s'est rendu compte que l'eau
arrivait à ce moment là mais il a fallu
que je protège on a eu juste le temps de
monter lundi à 11 heures nous étions ici
au standard de la caserne
deux heures plus tard les pompiers
devaient tout abandonner et voici ce
même standard aujourd'hui explication la
caserne inauguré il ya six mois a été
construite en zone inondable c'est
aberrant que confier ce et nous les
femmes nous installer ici on appris même
si on est refusé et milan voisin a visé
avait pourtant alerté la municipalité
il aura les weppes à faire là presque
taxes et des particuliers à la limite il
sort dans la merde pas ce mot mais on
les aide un v6 et les gendarmes et les
pompiers qui sont dans la merde
pourtant depuis 1996 d'organisation à
sommières obéit un plan de prévention
des risques mais en pratique on autorise
les installations comme ces nouveaux
lotissements en zone inondable avec pour
seule recommandation de surélever
l'habitation s'est classé zone à risque
quand même où jouer où j'ai fait
construire et comme le terrain ils
étaient abordables
c'est pour ça que j'ai ici délivrer le
permis de construire a été accepté
les équipes municipales précédentes ont
fait ses choix
choix financiers choix parce que vous
n'avez pas de terrain parce qu'on
n'avait pas de caserne
entre querelles politiques les
aberrations administratives
ce sont les sommiérois qui vont devoir
payer les dégâts oui la caserne
construite en zone inondable on va en
parler mais d'abord on va aller à cuxac
toujours dans l'aude car on a
l'impression que cette question
l'urbanisation est posée à chaque fois
mais que rien ne change ainsi à cuxac
les inondations de l'automne 99 il y a
trois ans avec les cinq morts 25 sur
l'ensemble du département
les choses ont elles changé réponse avec
vincent fort kent 13 novembre 1999 en
moins d'une demi-heure le village de
cuxac et noyé sous les cours l'aude est
en crue et rien ne résiste plus à ses
caprices
pas même ce remblai sur lequel passent
une voix faire quand il ses ventes une
vague de quatre mètres de haut se forme
pour tout dévaster sur son passage
mais voilà il y avait jusqu'ici à peu
près à ce jour là jean paul est chez lui
aujourd'hui il n'a rien oublié levy
consomme et celles qui disparaissent on
a récupéré quelques personnes qui ont pu
s'accrocher aux grillages à droite et à
gauche pour les mettre hors d'eau car
nous avions un étage
par contre pour d'autres personnes âgées
ont pu se sortir de leur maison est
hélas l'issue a été fatal trois ans plus
tard la colère des habitants n'est pas
retombée avec effroi ils ont vu le
fameux remblais se reformer un remblai
qui n'a jamais pu résister aux grands
crus de l'aude quatrième reconstruction
en un siècle à l'identique pour les
habitants les leçons du passé ont une
nouvelle fois été ignoré la voie ferrée
rue recasse et elle elle va partir en
quelques mpal elle et elle est passée
vieille scie en novembre ça arrive elle
va repartir va reprendre une vague quant
à nouveau vivre ce qu'on a vécu à 99,5
une ville toujours autant d'une mère
seul changement ou presque ces haut
parleurs pour alerter la population
quant au fameux plan de prévention des
risques
il n'a toujours pas vu le jour j'ai été
je crois inscrits par le préfet prescrit
par le peu frais en 1996
on nous annonce chaque six mois nous
annonçons au mois prochain
désabusés les habitants redoutent
maintenant la prochaine crue certains
n'ont d'ailleurs même pas pris la peine
d'effacer les traces de la précédente a
l'impression que c'est un peu la
débrouille
nicolas sarkozy alors il je peux pas
rentrer naturellement dans la situation
de chaque commune qu'ils s'administrent
librement
mais d'abord il faut reconnaître que si
nîmes n'a pas subi les dégâts qu'on
aurait pu craindre ses passes contre la
dernière crue et celle ci des travaux
ont été engagés il ya des bons est là
c'est nancy justice que de le dire on
peut pas jeter tout le monde dès qu'un
cri je comprends la colère je comprends
l'exaspération mais aussi des gens qui
ont travaillé qui ont fait des choses on
ne peut pas dire que rien n'a été fait
ça serais tu me semble-t-il non
équitable alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
maintenant
d'abord j'ai demandé aux préfets les
trois départements concernés le gard le
vaucluse l'hérault de revoir tous les
plans de prévention des risques avec les
services de l'environnement pour voir
s'ils conviennent et deuxièmement de se
donner des délais extrêmement bref pour
imposer des plans de prévention des
risques données communes qui n'en ont
pas et il faut que notre pays voit que
certaines communes qui en sont pourvus
il faut que notre pays aussi sorte une
culture d'irresponsabilité en france ont
détesté les règles quand y'a pas de
crise et quand il ya une crise tout le
monde créé en disant comment se fait-il
qu'il n'y ait pas de règle règle
d'ailleurs qu'on adore ce dont on adore
sa franchise donc il faut que ça cesse
une deuxième chose je me rendrai à la
demande du premier ministre et du
président de la république à nouveau le
21 septembre dans ces trois départements
nous ferons le point on va évaluer tous
les dégâts on va voir combien ça coûte
et déjà beaucoup trop lourd en termes de
vies humaines mais les conséquences
économiques pour les privés comme pour
les filières économiques et deuxièmement
on doit faire le point sur les
équipements structurants qui peuvent
manquer et qu'il conviendra d'engager la
sécurité sur tous les plans n'a pas de
prix et on s'en aperçoit lorsqu'à une
crise alors aujourd'hui le calendrier
est le suivant parce que j'imagine que
les malheureux qui sont dans cette
situation attendent de nous et de moi
autre chose que des discours et des
faits dès aujourd'hui la mission
d'évaluation désigné par le premier
ministre est sur place parce que
naturellement on peut pas décider
combien d'argent on va faire on va
donner pour la solidarité nationale et
son expression qu'on ne sait pas combien
ça coûte l'évaluation ça prend combien
de temps quelques jours en tout cas pour
les principaux ouvrages le 18 septembre
l'état de catastrophe naturelle sera
déclaré la commission sera réuni sa
présente un avantage très important
avantage il peut dire parce que ça
permet de rendre assurables des dommages
qui n'était pas ce qui est la
caractéristique de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
le 21 septembre à la demande du premier
ministre je me rendrai pour présider une
réunion de travail avec un certain
nombre de ministres je pense
sous-ministre et transport pour les
ouvrages aux ministres de
l'environnement ou pour la filière
agricole celui qui était déjà sans doute
qui reviendra de façon à ce qu'on voit
très exactement ce qu'on doit engager
mobiliser d'abord parce que les
collectivités peuvent pas rétablir les
voies de communication savez vous que
dans le gard l'état va s'ériger
massivement mais dans le gard c'est les
trois quarts des voies de circulation
qui était bloqué comment voulez-vous que
seul
ici faire face à un certain nombre
d'hommes et de femmes qui ont tout perdu
il faut bien qu'on leur tende la main
c'était la récolte pour la vendange tout
a été balayé en quelques heures
la filière viticole elle aussi doit être
aidée et enfin le 2 octobre le premier
ministre tiendra lui même un comité
interministériel à matignon pour décider
des premiers engagements financiers
notre idée est assez simple la
solidarité nationale doit s'exprimer
mais elle doit s'exprimer rapidement
c'est une question de crédibilité de la
parole publique
les gens attendent bien sûr des moyens
mais aussi des décisions rapides avec de
nouvelles procédures d'urgence merci
nicolas sarkozy mais restez avec nous
parce qu'on a aussi une question à vous
poser sur le terrorisme tout à l'heure
juste avant on va et pour clore ce
chapitre consacré aux inondations nous
allons dans le vaucluse à mornas pour
voir comment les enfants ont vécu ce
déluge ont-ils retrouvé aujourd'hui leur
habitude laurent dit christophe la
rocker malgré les inondations le
poney-club de mornas a décidé de rouvrir
ses portes pour les enfants privés
d'école jusqu'à demain c'est une bonne
occasion d'échanger leurs expériences
des derniers jours et si le monde
évidemment ne réagit pas de la même
façon je pense que ça surtout
impressionné les adultes et les petits
enfants en dessous de 10 ans et se sont
pas rendus compte qu'il ya de l'eau
partout bien génial une piscine je pense
pas qu'il sera du coup ça surtout à
l'armée les adultes
j'ai eu peur que ma maison soit inondée
oh
bruno 600 réfugiés et j'ai eu peur aussi
pour mon club parce que quand il ya ma
jument et houdain voilà
jamais vu un truc pareil
écriture
un petit peu quand la rabbia remonte
jusqu'à la maison comme on habite tout
près car tout remonter la vente maison
qui
zoom c'est ça qui me fait peur que ça se
reproduise l'ardèche monte monte monte
voilà qu'est ce que tu crois qu'on peut
faire pour éviter ça on ne peut pas
faire grand chose contre les éléments
surtout contrôlons le feu on pourrait
encore
avoir un jet d'eau et puis il éteint
mais le l'on peut prononcer à grand
chose il faudrait dit
abreu arrivé à détruire les nuages mais
bon c impossible voilà pour ce déluge
sur le sud est de la france
les cérémonies du 11 septembre
maintenant aux états unis un an jour
pour jour après les attentats une image
pour résumer l'émotion de cette journée
la ronde des familles des victimes du
world trade center ceux qui ont perdu un
être cher
elle était invitée une par une à faire
quelques pas pour déposer une fleur ou
un drapeau au milieu du chantier c'est
bertrand cocq et qui a suivi pour nous
cet hommage à washington et à new york
d'abord les cornemuses celle des
différents corps de pompiers de new york
et celle de la police leur marche lente
ont ouvert la cérémonie
puis le silence
un an après jour pour jour heure pour
heure à la minute précise où le premier
avion suicide percuté l'une des deux
tours jumelles il est 8 heures 46 et
l'amérique se tait
puis seul appel des morts
rudolf giuliani l'ancien maire de new
york entame la longue litanie des 2800
une victime du world trade center sur
l'esplanade une petite arène qui peu à
peu se couvre de fleurs
c'est le cercle de ceux qui sont
directement en deuil
les familles et les proches devant les
caméras de l'amérique devant tous leurs
concitoyens ils vont sobrement se
recueillir grande 0 ce matin l'épicentre
de l'émotion américaine presque au même
moment à shanksville en pennsylvanie
une autre cérémonie à la mémoire des
victimes du vol 93
le quatrième appareil celui qui s'était
écrasé la après que des passagers ait
tenté de désarmer les terroristes
le président américain de george bush et
son épouse arrivent au pentagone
symbole de la puissance militaire de
l'amérique et troisième cible des
attentats de l'année dernière ici aussi
cérémonie minute de silence puis george
bush devant les principaux membres de
son administration renouvelle sa
promesse de gagner la guerre contre le
terrorisme
ceux qui espéraient démoralisé notre
pays en choisissant ses cibles dit il
ceux là ont échoué
pendant 102 minutes ce matin la mairie
car vécu la tragédie du 11 septembre
2001 102 minutes le temps écoulé entre
le premier impact et l'effondrement de
la seconde tour 3025 nord et pour le
pays tout entier le choc de se découvrir
vulnérables 102 minutes de commémoration
autant pour se souvenir mais ils
n'oublieront jamais que pour se soutenir
car un an après l'amérique est toujours
en guerre
deux minutes de silence aussi à wall
street c'est rudolf giuliani l'ancien
maire qui a sonné la cloche pour ouvrir
la séance séance patriotique selon les
spécialistes les investisseurs tenait
semble-t-il à ce que l' indice dow jones
soit en haut c'est effectivement le cas
une façon de marquer que l'amérique doit
aller de l'avant
voyons maintenant comment les
new-yorkais ont vécu cette journée sur
place maryse burgot jean françois renaud
une vieille dame est venue avec la photo
de son fils plus loin c'est un mari
pompier qu'une épouse est venu pleurer
bien avant le début des cérémonies les
familles des victimes progresse vers
ground zero une lente procession qui les
aidera peut-être à faire enfin leur
deuil
il travaillait chez cantor fitzgerald
on l'avait 52 ans il avait deux filles
et un petit
son corps n'a jamais été retrouvé
alors pour nous ce jour marque vraiment
la fin de nos espoirs
il est toujours porté disparu alors que
le seul endroit où l'on se recueillir le
delà du périmètre de sécurité établi par
les forces de l'ordre
la foule des anonymes il ne connaissait
personne dans les tournois sont pourtant
là il écoute les noms des disparus qu'on
égrène un à un et cherche dans les
journaux le raisin les gens
louis barye aujourd'hui denis est en
état d'alerté maximum maison sommes
encore on ne voulait pas rester à la
maison on voulait être là demain ces
milliers de new yorkais y retournerons
travail et apaisée par cette journée de
commémoration
mais ils sont nombreux à penser que la
france fait il y a un nom à l'amérique
doit être ouvert
non et 1
la journée a été commémorée également
sur les bases américaines les plus en
pointe dans la lutte antiterroriste
comme ici à bagram en afghanistan
journée perturbée par des tirs qui
rappelle combien la situation est
précaire manifestations un peu partout
aussi dans les pays amis des etats unis
elles ont pris toutes les formes
possibles ici en australie c'est une
bannière étoilée qui a été formé vous le
voyez par les surfers rejoints par des
pompiers et des ambulanciers
un peu partout en europe les
gouvernements se sont associés à cet
hommage à paris jean-pierre raffarin
assiste en ce moment à un office
religieux en l'église américaine en
compagnie notamment du maire de paris
bertrand delanoë un peu plus tôt jacques
chirac avait participé à une cérémonie
du souvenir dans les jardins de
l'ambassade des états unis
on écoute en ce jour anniversaire si
douloureux je veux saluer la mémoire de
toutes les victimes
je veux rappeler l'héroïsme de celles et
de ceux qui ont pris tous les risques
pour sauver des vies je veux rendre
hommage au courage à la dignité au
patriotisme du peuple américain
exemplaire dans l'épreuve je veux dire à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous et à
travers vous à tous vos compatriotes
l'amitié la fidélité la solidarité de la
france notre volonté de lutter contre le
terrorisme international et de combattre
sans relâche la barbarie et les forces
de haine image aussi du pape jean paul
ii il a appelé tout à l'heure à prier
pour les victimes du 11 septembre et
pour le pardon divin aux terroristes
question maintenant comment cette
journée at-elle été vécue dans les pays
musulmans par exemple dans le monde
arabe au caire en egypte nos envoyés
spéciaux alain de chalvron didier dents
pas deux minutes de silence pas de
cérémonie du souvenir au caire en ce 11
septembre
la ville a connu sa frénésie habituelle
et pourtant chacun avait ici comme
ailleurs le souvenir de cette journée
tragique yom les rêves c'est un jour
terrible
c'est déconcertant sur le mot 25
les journaux ont consacré des pages
spéciales à cet anniversaire
mais les cafés qui croyait aller chez le
chaland en transmettant sur al jazeera
la sienne en arabe
les cérémonies de new york et washington
n'ont pas eu un franc succès les clients
paraissait plus intéressés par leur
narguilé ou leur partie de backgammon
que par le discours de george bush et a
égalé les américains dans 400 prendra
elle-même ben laden n'est rien d'autre
qu'une création américaine
nous ne haïssons pas les américains
ce que nous détestons c'est la politique
étrangère américaine
personne ne peut accepter la mort de
civils la regarder ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en palestine et demain en
irak
tiraillé entre une opinion publique de
plus en plus anti américaine et une
relation stratégique avec les états unis
le gouvernement égyptien estime s'en
être plutôt bien tiré un an après il en
serait tout autrement si demain l'irak
devait être attaqué par l'amérique
on va y venir manifestations d'hostilité
en thaïlande
devant l'ambassade des états unis à
bangkok des bouddhistes et des
manifestants musulmans se sont
rassemblées pour scander des slogans
anti américains et anti mondialisation
on retrouve etienne leenhardt en duplex
de new york c'est vrai etienne que le
monde comme les américains à l'esprit le
11 septembre mais aussi sans doute une
guerre qui semble en préparation celle
des états unis contre l'irak demande
george bush s'adressa aux nations unies
est-ce que ce discours est attendu comme
le début du compte à rebours
oui en fait toute la communication du
président américain david a été
savamment dosé savamment articuler ce
matin c'était le temps de l'hommage aux
familles et il leur a dit vos proches ne
sont pas morts en vain et nous gagnerons
cette guerre tous les gens qui
compléteront les terroristes et les
dictateurs qui complèteront contre nous
nous les attaquerons et le ton va se
durcir dès ce soir puisque il prononcera
un discours depuis le pied de la statue
de la liberté discours retransmis en
direct à la télévision
et puis alors demain matin devant
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
il pourrait lancer un véritable
ultimatum à saddam hussein et il
interpellera la communauté
internationale pour qu'elle soutienne
une communauté qui est solidaire
lorsqu'il s'agit de partager la peine et
la tristesse des américains mais qui
l'est beaucoup moins on le sait
lorsqu'il s'agit d'envisager une attaque
contre l'irak
ce qui est certain en tout cas david
sait que plus le président o sera le
tour dans la rhétorique guerrière plus
il va lui être difficile dans un futur
très proche de ne rien faire s'ils
aventure saddam hussein refuse et bien
de taxer les à la demande des états unis
vous savez le retour des inspecteurs en
désarmement des nations unies merci
etienne on sait en tout cas qu un très
important dispositif de sécurité avait
été mise en place pour ces cérémonies la
période est considérée comme sensible en
france aussi la protection de l'espace
aérien par exemple est toujours assurée
en permanence depuis le 11 septembre
nous avons pu assister il ya quelques
heures un début d' alerte à taverny
reportage jérôme soûlard eric de
l'agneau la viande avait fait quatre
morts
à la base aérienne de reims une alerte
vient d'être déclenchée le pilote
d'astreinte et son mirage 2000 armé de
quatre missiles doit intercepté au plus
vite un avion suspect depuis le 11
septembre
on surveille particulièrement les avions
arrivant du maghreb au plan de vol
défaillant le pilote du mirage 2000 à
moins de 15 minutes pour arriver au
contact si l'avion de ligne n'obéit pas
il devra la battre c'est le premier
ministre de son bureau qui en donnera
l'ordre
depuis le 11 septembre nous avons
multiplié par 6 par six le nombre de
décollages et de vérification dans le
ciel français
quand je crois que c'est extrêmement
important parce que ça montre aux
terroristes que nous sommes très
présents et que nous avons élevé le
niveau de vigilance derrière cette porte
bien gardé 15 km de galeries secrète
taverny banlieue nord de paris c'est ici
le coeur du commandement de la défense
aérienne française 24 heures sur 24
ces militaires du pc opérationnel
surveille sans relâche notre espace
aérien
dix mille avions par jour inscrits sur
ce tableau en vigilance maximum depuis
le 11 septembre le commandement de la
défense aérienne française a déclenché
près d'une alerte par jour aucun
incident majeur n'a pour l'instant été
signalé nicolas sarkozy question simple
la menace reste très important donc les
mesures de sécurité aussi mais la guerre
contre le terrorisme n'aura jamais de
fin est-ce qu'il faut se préparer à
vivre avec un plan vigipirate renforcé
en permanence en france mais vous
trouvez que c'est une question simple un
enfant la vigilance il faut vivre avec
parce que la france est d'une grande
démocratie et que les ennemis de la
démocratie que sont les terroristes qui
ont pu commettre des actes aussi
barbares le mal absolu
il ya un an sont les adversaires de
toutes les démocraties dont de la france
la vigilance s'impose à chacun d'entre
nous cela veut dire aussi développer nos
capacités de renseignement pour pouvoir
intervenir le plus en amont possible
comme cela a été fait par les services
c'est moi et ses années passées pour
éviter des drames et leur cortège
d'horreurs
mais ces mesures de sécurité il faut se
préparer à vivre avec pendant des mois
des années en tout cas c'est le vous
envisagé dans les agendas les jeunes
disposant cette vigilance nous devons
vivre avec sans doute moderniser à la
demande du président de la république le
plan vigipirate qui a quelque peu changé
de nature par rapport à ce qu il devait
tête il y a dix ou quinze ans cela aussi
doit demander au gouvernement français
beaucoup de fermeté à l'endroit de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont sur
notre territoire et qui aurait lien
direct ou indirect avec des réseaux
terroristes
ils n'ont pas vocation à y rester cela
veut dire également le développement de
ce que nous ne savions pas bien faire en
france qu'est la protection civile
avec une réserve civile avec des études
très anticipé sur les risques
bactériologiques pour que tous les
éléments de sécurité soit donnée à notre
compatriote comme les autres démocraties
la france est sous la menace le 11
septembre plus aujourd'hui il ya 70
c'est une réalité avec laquelle nous
devons apprendre à vivre et c'est
justement parce que nous serons être
vigilant et que nous aurons la sagesse
de ne pas baisser la garde
ce qui a été fait par le gouvernement
avec notamment la loi de programmation
militaire passait devant l'australie en
nombre aujourd'hui même à la demande du
président de la république c'est parce
que nous serons vigilants que nous
pourrons préserver autant que faire ce
peu nos compatriotes de ces événements
dramatiques
merci nicolas sarkozy notre enquête
maintenant sur l'un de ces français qui
auraient choisi le djihad non pas en
afghanistan mais en tchétchénie il
s'appelle khaled ould ali né dans le
gard algérien d'origine il a été arrêté
par les autorités géorgiennes qu'il
accuse de complicité avec le terrorisme
cet homme
notre équipe a pu le rencontrer
dominique derda franck brisset khaled
ould ali a de quoi se faire du soucis
nés dans le gard en 1968 de parents
algériens le jeune français risque de 8
à 15 ans de détention
c'est en présence de son avocat et d'un
agent des services de sécurité que nous
l'avons rencontré dans sa prison
vous êtes accusé d'avoir des liens avec
une organisation terroriste
c'est totalement font totalement fou
quand quelqu'un qui s'y passe comme je
leur ai dit si je si j'étais lié à une
organisation terroriste
je viendrai avec mon passeport mon
passeport je n'ai même pas avec des
visas tiendrait pas en taxi j'ai même
pas si flagrant c'est trop bon son
volant il ya trop de choses qui descend
qui sont évidents points arrêté le 25
août dernier près de la vallée de
pankisi khaled ould ali est un suspect
idéal étrangers musulman de surcroît il
a dans ses bagages des livres de prières
et cache sous ses vêtements civils
un pantalon de treillis de plus dans son
interrogatoire il reconnaît avoir déjà
franchi clandestinement la frontière en
1999 et séjourner près d'un an
tchétchénie
quand ils ont vu par nyon qu'une colonne
de peu
ce qu'ils gagnent a vite obligé de
changer de région ou de village ou de
trucs de s'en aller ou alors de se
cacher non dans les montagnes avec les
civils avec les jeunes des jeunes gens
alors six mois on entre à pas avec eux
restez mois va m'accuser d'être un air
combattants comme ça non mais le mieux
c'était d'aller avec eux est plus là moi
je me dis vraiment là je me suis rendu
compte ce qui se passait c'est vraiment
oui c'est vraiment ce qui se passe et
continue par des chemins de traverse via
l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie khaled est
de retour en france en novembre 2000 dès
lors il n'a qu'une idée en tête revenir
dans le caucase à s'offrir le voyage
il travaillera jusqu'à cet été au marché
de rungis comme manutentionnaire ont la
vérité c'est que j'ai voulu aller
vraiment à aider il dit comme je voulais
plus moralement cre est réfugié titienne
aller les voir surtout voir comment
leurs conditions de vie et à et voilà sa
famille qui vit dans la banlieue de
bordeaux
merci à l'aide dit qu'il n'a fait que
son devoir qu'il n'a aucun regret la
justice géorgienne se donne trois mois
pour établir ou non sa culpabilité
la sécurité toujours c'est dans ce
contexte du 11 septembre que la nouvelle
loi de programmation militaire on
l'évoqué il ya un instant loi de
programmation pour les années 2003 2008
a été adopté en conseil des ministres il
s'agit de faire face aux nouvelles
menaces pour reprendre les termes de
jacques chirac principal projet un
deuxième porte avions tiré kurt et le
porte avions charles de gaulle aura donc
un petit frère
celui ci devra entrer en service avant
2012 celle annonce la plus spectaculaire
de cette nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire
le gouvernement a fait de la défense
l'une de ses priorités
le budget du ministère augmentera de 6 %
en 2003 les crédits d'équipement et
d'achats de matériels augmenteront et de
12%
les programmes les plus lourds concerne
l'armée de l'air avec la confirmation
des commande de 50 avions de transport
a400m pour remplacer les vieux transall
feu vert aussi pour les chasseurs
bombardiers rafale
l'effort portera également sur
l'entretien ou la mise à niveau des
matériels existants poste important
lorsque l'on sait que par exemple 50%
des hélicoptères de combat sont
actuellement cloués au sol faute de
pièces de rechange 572 millions d'euros
seront consacrés à des mesures
attractives qui permettront de garder
une arme est jeune il faut d'un côté un
tit au départ ceux qui sont en fin de
contrat en leur assurant des formations
pour pouvoir de l'eau
côté recruté environ trente mille
personnes par an en bref le climat
électrique de ce 11-septembre y est il
pour quelque chose
en tout cas un élève de 3e de ce collège
d'asnières dans les hauts-de-seine a
volontairement lancé une bouteille
d'acide chlorhydrique assure ses
camarades 14 d'entre eux ont été
examinés pas de blessures graves
le maire de la ville a évoqué un acte
terroriste deux ministres xavier darcos
et nicolas sarkozy qui était avec nous
ont même fait le déplacement mais plutôt
pour calmer le jeu les professeurs
estiment qu'il s'agit d'un enfant agité
et perturbateurs à saint brieuc en ille
et vilaine la condamnation d'un père de
famille à trois mois de prison avec
sursis
il avait giflé le directeur de l'école
l'accusion de harceler son fils de 8 ans
le débat sur la prostitution avec donc
cette première judiciaire à bordeaux ce
sont des clients qui sont poursuivis
officiellement pour exhibition sexuelle
leur éventuelle condamnation pourrait
ouvrir la voie à une interdiction de
fait de la prostitution comme en suède
éric perrin c'est une première quatre
clients et quatre prostituées sont
poursuivis pour exhibition sexuelle au
tribunal correctionnel de bordeaux
ces procès sont la suite logique des
opération policière lancée depuis deux
mois dans la ville qui se veut à la
pointe en matière de lutte contre la
prostitution conjointement services de
police et justice ont décidé de ne pas
limiter la répression au seul proxénètes
et prostituées mais de dissuader les
clients interpellation garde à vue
inculpation
l'offre on peut dire
existera le seul moyen de faire des 1000
commerces et de gnl le cliente
peut-on retenir le chef d'exhibition
sexuelle à l'encontre des quatre
prévenus interpellés dans le feu de
l'action en compagnie des prostituées
dans leur voiture pour leur avocat qui
ont tous demandé la relaxe cela ne tient
pas du strict point de vue juridique car
selon eux il n'y a jamais eu intention
d'exhibition des avocats qui dénoncent
par ailleurs la médiatisation de ces
opérations
on veut faire de l'exemplaire ou faire
du spectaculaire au procès de son père
jugement exemplaire
j'attends un jugement exemplaire qui
recadre ray le problème juridique de tir
on verra le parquet à ses chères études
les prévenus risquent un an
d'emprisonnement et 15 mille euros
damende il faudra attendre le 9 octobre
prochain pour connaître la décision si
ses clients devaient finalement être
condamné ce serait une première en
france qui pourrait faire jurisprudence
reste à apprécier l'efficacité d'une
telle politique policière et judiciaire
dans la lutte contre la prostitution les
fumeurs interdit de première classe à la
sncf la décision a été prise par la
compagnie qui a constaté une baisse
régulière des réservations de places
fumeurs baisse de 2 à 3 % chaque année
et angie qu'elle caroline katia boissons
allez monsieur le contrôleur une petite
dernière
éteignez vos cigarettes le tgv 72,50 va
partir à compter du 15 décembre la
société nationale des chemins de fer
français ne mégote plus
l'espace vital des accros de la nicotine
se réduit comme une peau de chagrin
si vous voulez fumée en voyageant oublié
déjà la première classe seul un wagon de
secondes vous sera accessible alors
évidemment chez les fumeurs ont tous
combien une telle stabilisation donné
fumeurs
qui sait très légalement personnellement
ça ne fait pas très plaisir parce que je
suis actionnaire avaient été ré et je
trouve que trop c'est trop
à l'autre bout de la ram chez les non
fumeurs
la mesure fait un tabac ou entendu aux
fumeurs savent rien mais je comprendrais
que des fumeurs savoir passer un petit
souci moi ça me va très bien
pour la direction sncf toutes les
protestations ne sont qu'un écran de
fumée
les chiffres sont là soixante pour cent
des fumeurs ne réserve pas une place en
fumeurs ils vont fumer dans la voiture
fumeurs mais prennent pour eux mêmes une
place non fumeurs si vous ne voulez pas
définitivement l'écraser il vous restera
tout de même 50 places sur les 500 que
compte un tgv jusqu'à nouvel ordre
du football pour terminer avec d'abord
un résultat nice vient de battre
marseille 2-0 incidents dans les
tribunes
des supporters marseillais six blessés à
cause d'un pétard sur le terrain ce très
beau coup franc du brésilien everson
pour le premier but second but signé ou
nous fallait sur cette action
nice qui conforte sa première place au
classement du championnat avec 13 points
hier soir je vous rappelle qu'en match
avancé lyon avait battu lens 1 0 but
inscrit par juninho un brésilien a
encore faim de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi à suivre la météo patrice
drevet l'info sur france 2 une heure
dernier journal jean claude renault
demain dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra jean françois mattei le
ministre de la santé
on se quitte avec ses images de
l'hommage de venise aux victimes du 11
septembre
un autre c
moi si
lui